[Music]
very sad news
shinzo abe who was the ex-prime minister
of japan has been assassinated that's
crazy crazy during a campaign stop so he
was there to like give a political
speech and then this guy comes up behind
him with a makeshift shotgun that he
made with pipes damn and he shoots in
the back like a little [ __ ] frankly
yeah and as he was following they shoot
him in the front too they did the back
in the front his chest there's chest and
a back was it two assassins or just one
just one i think i think i think he got
shot and then he like turned and he fell
and he shot him again yeah it could be
that because it was like as he was
falling he got shot again and then as
soon as the second shot went off um the
secrets the guard or whatever just
tackled them yeah and then they dock
piled them
it's crazy they said after the this 41
year old [ __ ] assassin river like
shot he didn't like at all even remotely
try to flee the scene it's like shot and
you stood there and watched it is he
trying to be a martyr is that why like
yeah that was me
no one knows motive man like it's crazy
and the way that this guy looks
like you could see what he looks like
[ __ ] geek bro he doesn't look like an
assassin
[ __ ] yeah he looks like a
man he looks like a jk news editor yeah
basically hey [ __ ] you hey [ __ ] you hey
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and
the weapon he made you know how it's
always like like uh like when james bond
comes back to the weapons room right
they're like hey hey james you're gonna
like what i what i mean you know like he
looks like the guy the guy that makes
the weapon not the guy that shoots the
weapon yeah like his shotgun actually
looks pretty legit like all the firing
mechanisms that you need it's a really
interesting mechanism on that so it's
like a it's like a pipe gun so you can
make those pretty easily actually out of
like just um like like plumbing pipe
yeah um and then there is but the
coolest part about it is that there's
like an electronic firing mechanism on
it so he's got a big ass [ __ ] rc
battery strap to it yeah and then that
remote um trigger is what sparks it off
and then he probably from what i'm
reading about it it was probably like
black powder which was probably homemade
so he like concocted it himself and then
filled it with like slugs or yeah
whatever it was shotgun or it sounded
like well it's a it's it's a homemade
shotgun but you didn't get but it wasn't
actually they're pretty sure that it
wasn't an actual shotgun shell because
that's what i was curious about when i
first heard about it because guns in
japan it's hard dude you can own a
shotgun for like sporting and hunting
purposes but you have to
check it into a very specific like
storage space and then you have to go
check it out so you can't even have it
normally like you have to go take it out
for very specific reasons yeah and it's
super closely monitored so i was like
okay then how the [ __ ] did he get like
ammunition for it but it's i guess what
they're theorizing is right now is that
it's all mostly handmade stuff which is
like really interesting because yeah
which is kind of crazy because that's
what i've been saying or a lot of has
been saying too right where like gun
control doesn't really spread or doesn't
stop the spread of guns i think that
just where there's a will there's a way
yeah cause there's a ton of gun control
over there right and you got geeks
making them [ __ ]
yeah but isn't it good if you could take
a gun out like if somebody needs a gun
to protect themselves isn't it good that
you could take that gun out of their
hands
and and like
you have their gun generally yeah that's
that's what i said no but they were
there but they were also reporting that
japan hasn't had like a gun killing uh
they only had one in 2020 they have a
lot of stabbings yeah there's always
mass stabbings happening yeah they're
trying to ban knives now yeah yeah yeah
they have like drop-off box in the uk
with knives so i will say that like yeah
japan generally has a lot of like
japan's relatively safe and they do have
not very many like gun related deaths
because yeah there's no [ __ ] but in
crime in general it's
very low in japan in general yeah it's
in general is just a like petty theft
and all that [ __ ] super low like you
could [ __ ] go out there and it's like
feel safe as hell you know to the point
where you can still assassinate a former
prime minister with a homemade gun which
is crazy i guess it's pretty common in
japan for them for the for politicians
to meet their constituents super close
because if this were in the u.s like you
couldn't you probably couldn't get that
close to a um to like somebody doing it
i think it'd be almost impossible yeah
because our security's so tight because
we have that kind of threat from what i
understand like uh like let's say if a
president is going to go somewhere here
or like a commander-in-chief regardless
of who it is who it is right it's like
12 hours before and 12 hours after that
airspace is closed so that's already
locked down then you got [ __ ] decoy
cars and [ __ ] like that then they they
also understand they got like secret
service on in the sewers and like they
already have [ __ ] up in the
windows like pretending to [ __ ] like
be a grandma getting a perm except they
got a [ __ ] ak right here just ready
it's like everything is [ __ ] [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out like biden was in in la
like recently
the president thank you thank you thank
you
all the freeways and stuff like we're
closed during that time there's like
streets that were closed off and stuff
like that remember when [ __ ] hillary
was campaigning over here and she wasn't
even
like president or anything at the moment
right but we heard those [ __ ]
helicopters for like five hours straight
chinooks bro they were going all over
dude it was [ __ ] loud yeah that's why
they didn't vote for her she's obnoxious
i was pissed about traffic they secure
the whole area how come they didn't
secure the area for this guy see japan's
too safe one of my ways of voting
actually is like if you cut me off in
traffic and you have your bumper sticker
that's a vote against
that's why bernie didn't win too many
people have bernie stickers and then
they're just like you know what you
prius driving bernie supporters [ __ ] you
and they keep cutting off and i see you
too like you're [ __ ] fiddling around
with your phone cause you're trying to
get your your podcast on your latest
progressive topic like switched over in
time but then you're coming into my lane
so like that's why i didn't vote for
your guy actually i voted against my own
interests
[Laughter]
uh but no but by election day if your
guy cuts me off the day of oh i'm voting
for the guy yeah definitely you know i
saw a news article that was saying that
this uh type of incident in terms of the
magnitude and the scale and the
experience is like comparable to like j
f kennedy's association
in america you know what i mean to have
a foreign prime minister uh or the
former uh japanese prime minister who
was like the longest reigning prime
minister he had like the longest term
wow to just be gunned down by a single
individual in the streets and he was
campaigning to go a goal to run again
yeah so i think this guy was trying to
stop him and npr is by the way whack
i don't know if you guys i don't know if
you guys saw this what about vr well no
they they called him some right-wing
extremist today like abby during his
yeah during his obituary npr was like
right wing extremist known for it's like
a whisper bro he was cool to obama he
was cool with trump he was cool like to
america like for a reason because japan
and us have good relations which is good
for his country but that's the weirdest
thing i've ever heard weird [ __ ] it was
super weird i i just saw this while i
was looking losing their touch huh why
would people hate him is there anything
about well he was a far right wing
extremist
with any like politician like no matter
which like there's no there's no
politician that's universally loved
right like there's nobody
there's always things that like i mean
that presidents or you know political
people do wrong that you can find a
reason to hate them so especially if
you're one of the affected people that
like gets [ __ ] up by their policies
and yeah like obviously there's a reason
i think he was the first prime minister
that was born um after the war ii
because like previous to that all the
people in power everybody
was there when the sad [ __ ] happened
right so they remember all that [ __ ] i
think he was the first prime minister
that wasn't um a part of that era like
he's a boomer yeah um
he's like what happened to nagasaki
i don't remember
i was interested in the shooter and i
was trying to figure out what the motive
was or whatever but there's a rumor
right now that this guy was from the
japanese defense force oh [ __ ] so that's
my job yeah or i don't know like he's a
former military dude
maybe unhappy with the government
whatever it is
but when i looked at him again i said
this guy does not fit the description he
looks like a [ __ ] geek he looks like
a [ __ ] i thought he's following a
covet protocol keeping the mask on it i
did i did like that i thought that was
i'm
assassinated i don't want to give shinzo
abe corona yeah i just want to give him
a couple in the back
it probably helps him blend in though
like having a mask on yeah it's just
wild because that's not why that's not
why that's not why he's worried about
corona yeah any time like a a president
right from maybe like
okay when you when you when you think
about like maybe a poor country you kind
of think oh they're always [ __ ]
shooting each other or whatever there's
always warlords taking over the
government or whatever there's
insurrection or whatever but when you
see that happening to like let's say a
first world nation that's also extremely
safe country to me it's like the swedish
prison
president got shot or whatever it's like
what the [ __ ] that blows my mind because
i'm like who
who who do they get mad like i get if
like one of our presidents get [ __ ] up
cause it's like everyone's always pissed
and always talking about killing them
and [ __ ] that's what they do here yeah
yeah but they don't expect that we hate
them yeah
yeah but then like [ __ ] i don't know
like someone like the the german
chancellor or some [ __ ] like i don't
know
and and hello
i don't know i think she's stepping out
i feel like she's not anymore hey [ __ ]
you man i don't know who the replacement
is edit that out now to google it maybe
look really really smart or like the
danish or the danish like president
right or like whatever
denmark just had a mass shooting yeah
denmark
did they really
i don't know man i guess that's a guy
named olaf
that's a good strong american name
that's a villainous olaf shorts
sounds like as a snowman oh
that's crazy man the whole world's
[ __ ] losing it but i feel like i feel
like any country that it has like
because i mean we obviously have like
the crazy people on the internet that
are in our country that are like oh yeah
i'm totally gonna assassinate the
president i feel like that's gotta be
the same in like just about every
country there's gonna be like one
job that's in some [ __ ] like sub
forum that's like oh yeah and i built a
bunch of guns in my basement and i'm
gonna go do this and everyone's like
yeah [ __ ] crazy person and they do
and you're like oh that's crazy son of a
[ __ ] did it who knew john hinckley jr
yeah cool john hinckley jr he shot
reagan and he was like i'm doing this
[ __ ] believe it or not
for jodie foster
oh i remember that yeah why why why was
that he was upset she was she was
i don't know if you understand how this
works because maybe you've never had a
woman love you from afar oh
right no it's always by closing
communicating with him through her eyes
in film and television didn't have all
those tv set up where you just look at
her face for like hours and he's just
staring at it like getting messages from
her that he thinks is real and yeah dude
it's like that she's like they were real
right
no [ __ ] no
the answers are so [ __ ] juice
[Laughter]
that's good dancers don't know what the
[ __ ] going on dude i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on beyond it i can't
believe my vote equals his vote
i
am a talk show host okay dancer's my
former life
oh [ __ ] if you could just recognize are
you intoxicated and respect damn oh damn
he [ __ ] he threw the king at you i
host a news show is that right loosely
it's a respectable job guys thank you
we talk about hey look we get diverted
sometimes because sometimes titties need
to be real big
i swear to god if you bring it back to
balancing balancing excuse me the word
is balanced who's the bounciest
president you've ever seen
yo
hey we haven't had one yet that's the
problem the croatian president
she's small are we not talking about
nancy pelosi
oh nancy has some heavies for sure but
she's not president she's starting
[ __ ] taft though
that's just bouncy as [ __ ] bro you
[ __ ] pushed that guy down the stairs
he was bouncing around half had big ones
big ones all right go look at the
croatian president she's hot really is
she the hottest person of croatia dude
she's [ __ ] smoking hot dude how do
you know that
how how big you think dude it's a dude
right now
the president of croatia oh my god oh sh
really it's like that kind of reaction
the heaviest of heavy whoa she's really
oh she could be laura she's no she's no
[ __ ] nancy pelosi she could be laura
is this chick this chick looks like ice
cube's white
[Laughter]
yeah
hey look she has my vote i don't know
who she is i'm team nancy all day dude
shouldn't we be moving to croatia i
think i'm gonna look
you know what i heard they don't have
any gun crimes in croatia
i wonder i think that's a lie
i don't know that i'm sure about that i
didn't look it up gun crimes in croatia
holy [ __ ] they got missile crimes though
oh dude they got no they got [ __ ] fun
bags crying
game of thrones was filmed there so i
mean it's really good uh you know just
relatability bliss culture what's her
name
doesn't even matter
croatian president her name is oh i
forgot what your name is i'm looking at
your titties again
hey
you guys will not disappoint with my
recommendations that's all i'm saying
i'm telling you joe has the hookups
sorry second second bounciest president
in the world go
wow
oh the president of latvia have you seen
her holy [ __ ] really giant one are you
scared look her up i heard they're as
big as an infant's head yeah dude
latvian some as big as your head it's a
dude shut up
what about the one before the current
one maybe it's up it means the one
before dude i'm not gonna look that
[ __ ] far back
what about the hottest first ladies of
the world hottest dudes melanie trump
definitely come on i mean she was a mom
i'm more of a laura bush kind of guy oh
hey laura laura
nice little bob you know more had some
sneaky sneakies
this [ __ ] listicle artist some inside
jobs if you know what i mean top 10
hottest first ladies of america number
10 is barbara bush
what get out of here we got love
standers probably dude michelle obama
comes next and then and then pat nixon
what the [ __ ] what is this listicle now
we're not doing i don't know what this
is no jackie onassis was pretty hot
jackie o'ness was hot but not she wasn't
melania trump no no no you're right come
on what about elizabeth warren she's
fired she's part
there's like an extra 10 points there
what oh yeah
i don't even know what to say to that
you know what we gotta we gotta we gotta
choose the era hey i'd go to that
reservation you know what i'm saying if
if senator elizabeth warren is there
let's go let's talk about it let's talk
about it for an hour
[Music]
you